América Latina es una de las regiones más
pobres, más violentas y para colmo más azotadas
por el coronavirus de todo el planeta.
Para que os hagáis una idea, se estima que
más del 30% de todas las muertes por la Covid-19
se han producido en Latinoamérica.
Sí, sí, lo habéis escuchado bien. A pesar
de suponer menos del 9% de la población mundial,
los datos disponibles apuntan a que podrían
haber sido el epicentro más castigado por
la Covid-19. 1 de cada 3 víctimas mortales.
Esa es la estimación en el momento de preparar
este vídeo.
Y no importa si el resultado final es 1 de
cada 3, 1 cada de cada 4 o 1 de cada 6. Sea
como sea todo apunta a que, una vez más,
también en esta crisis América Latina se
ha llevado la peor parte.
("La pandemia está golpeando duramente América
Latina [...] que es el epicentro del sufrimiento
de la Covid-19”. Carissa Etienne, Directora
de la Organización Panamericana de la Salud.)
Tal y como os podéis imaginar esta es una
situación que tiene consecuencias políticas,
económicas y sociales.
(Cubans Denounce ‘Misery’ in Biggest Protests
in Decades. The rallies, widely viewed as
astonishing for a country that limits dissent,
were set off by economic crises worsened by
the pandemic. NYTimes)
(Cubanos denuncian la "miseria" en las mayores
protestas en décadas
Las concentraciones, ampliamente consideradas
como sorprendentes en un país que limita
la disidencia, fueron desencadenadas por la
crisis económica agudizada por la pandemia.
NYTimes)
Mucho ánimo desde aquí, desde VisualPolitik
a todos los cubanos que hartos de tanto oprobio,
tiranía y miseria han dicho basta.
[¿Podrá el coronavirus asentar un golpe
de gracia al régimen castrista?
Mucha fuerza y ánimo. Tienen que llegar mejores
días para la perla del caribe. Tienen que
estar al caer.]
Pero el ejemplo de Cuba no es ni mucho menos
el único.
(El izquierdista Pedro Castillo se impone
en un Perú partido en dos. El maestro rural
que busca «reescribir la historia» será
el presidente del país andino tras un ajustado
triunfo. ABC)
Precisamente, hablando de Perú, hace un tiempo
os contamos en VisualPolitik cómo invertir
en una mujer peruana podía ser tan rentable
como invertir en el mismísimo S&P 500, el
índice bursátil más importante del mundo.
Pero, ahora bien, ¿sigue siendo esto así
tras la pandemia? ¿Cuál ha sido el impacto
del coronavirus en estos entornos y este tipo
de inversión tan particular? ¿Sigue teniendo
sentido invertir en una emprendedora peruana
en lugar de en la bolsa norteamericana?
Y quizás la pregunta más importante de todas,
¿Qué pueden hacer realmente los países
más ricos para apoyar que América Latina
de una vez por todas se ponga en vías de
acabar con la pobreza?
Queridos amigos, amigas de VisualPolitik,
en este vídeo que hemos preparado gracias
a la ayuda de nuestros amigos de Microwd,
os vamos a contar qué está ocurriendo, por
qué demonios América Latina no despega y
por qué el último plan de Joe Biden para
esta región puede ser algo así como la historia
de un fracaso anunciado.
Por cierto, para los que aún no lo conozcáis,
Microwd es una empresa de impacto social que
da microcréditos sin aval a mujeres emprendedoras
de regiones muy pobres en países como Nicaragua,
Perú o México. Una fórmula que está explotando
en los últimos tiempos y que puede llegar
a ser muy útil para las comunidades
más pobres.
Os dejamos el link en la descripción por
si queréis conocer mejor este proyecto y
todo lo que puede ofreceros.
Amigos, amigas, prestad atención porque no
creo que este vídeo os deje indiferentes.
(USA TIENE UN PLAN)
El coronavirus ha tenido un impacto enorme
en todo el mundo, pero tal y como os podéis
imaginar en los países más pobres sus consecuencias
pueden llegar a ser muchísimo peores.
Y, claro, si a la pobreza, le añadimos la
criminalidad, la violencia y la falta de oportunidades,
entonces la cosa empieza a preocupar a los
países más ricos, ¿por qué? Pues porque
es el caldo de cultivo perfecto para la emigración.
Y si hablamos de América Latina entonces
hablamos de Estados Unidos. Fijaos.
(25 de junio de 2021: “Detenciones en la
frontera sur de Estados Unidos superan el
millón en año fiscal 2021. Al ritmo actual,
el total de detenciones en la frontera para
el año fiscal, que termina el 30 de septiembre,
sería el más alto desde el 2000. Euronews)
Y si hablamos de Estados Unidos hablamos tradicionalmente
de México y sobre todo últimamente también
de lo que se conoce como el triángulo norte,
esto es Guatemala, Honduras y El Salvador.
Tres países que forman según los propios
datos de Naciones Unidos uno de los espacios
más pobres, corruptos y peligrosos de todo
el mundo.
Pero ahora Estados Unidos, Estados Unidos
tiene un plan.
No, no, no...No me refiero a esto, sino a
este otro:
(Biden quiere dar 4.000 millones de dólares
en ayuda a Honduras, El Salvador y Guatemala
para reducir la inmigración.DailyMail)
Joe Biden le ha encomendado a su flamante
VicePresidenta, Kamala Harris, que lidere
un plan multimillonario con el que enfrentar
de raiz el problema de la inmigración ilegal.
La idea es que si la inmigración tiene que
ver con la pobreza, la violencia y la falta
de oportunidades, entonces esta enorme inversión
tiene que contribuir a frenarla.
Por ejemplo, se estima que cuando el PIB per
cápita de un país sobrepasa los 8.000 dólares,
entonces el interés por emigrar, sobre todo
a emigrar ilegalmente, se reduce sustancialmente.
Pero claro, el problema es que el PIB per
cápita de Guatemala y El Salvador se sitúa
en torno a los 4.000 dólares y el de Honduras
en unos 2.500.
Es decir, están muy lejos de ese umbral de
los 8.000 USD. De ahí que Biden quiera inyectar
un montón de dinero en la región.
Suena bien, ¿verdad? Pues… Amigos, esperad
un momento, antes de lanzar las campanas al
vuelo, porque a veces las intenciones y los
resultados no van de la mano. Pero para entender
toda esta historia empecemos por el principio.
(Durante décadas el patrón regular de la
emigración a Estados Unidos pasaba porque
fueran los mexicanos quienes trataran de cruzar
la frontera en busca de una vida mejor. Sin
embargo, en 2014 se produjo un cambio de tendencia:
una avalancha de familias centroamericanas
y niños no acompañados de esta misma región
comenzó a llegar a la frontera sur de Estados
Unidos.)
Y, pregunta, ¿qué pensáis que hizo el gobierno
norteamericano? Pues en ese momento a la Administración
Obama se le encendió la bombilla: ¿por qué
no luchar contra la inmigración directamente
en el origen?
Y así fue como nació la Alianza por la Prosperidad
del Triángulo Norte. Al frente de la cual,
Obama puso al actual presidente Joe Biden.
(La Alianza estratégica para la prosperidad
del Triángulo Norte de América Central fue
el plan propuesto por la administración de
Barack Obama para impulsar el desarrollo de
la región centroamericana.
Hasta el 2014, la colaboración entre Estados
Unidos y estos países se había dado fundamentalmente
en materia de seguridad a través del Plan
Mérida puesto en marcha por George Bush primero,
y más tarde con el CARSI, la Iniciativa de
Seguridad Regional de Centroamérica puesta
en marcha por Obama en 2009. Dos planes a
través de los cuales Estados Unidos ha destinado
más de 1.000 millones de dólares para entrenar
y reforzar los cuerpos de seguridad de la
región.
Sin embargo, la Alianza para la Prosperidad
pretendía impulsar no solo la seguridad sino
también el desarrollo de estos países.)
De esta forma, hasta 2018 se calcula que Estados
Unidos invirtió en proyectos de desarrollo,
seguridad y gobernando unos 2.400 millones
de dólares. Unos 1.100 millones en Guatemala,
unos 750 en Honduras y casi 500 en El Salvador.
(“Cuando fui vicepresidente, me centré
en proporcionar la ayuda necesaria para abordar
estas causas fundamentales de la migración.
Ayudó a mantener a la gente en sus propios
países en lugar de obligarla a marcharse.
Nuestro plan funcionó”. Joe Biden.).
Pero, no, el problema es que no funcionó.
Tras gastarse miles de millones las cosas
no han mejorado sustancialmente y desde luego
la inmigración sigue llegando.
Y por eso la nueva idea es redoblar esfuerzos.
Y si en el primer plan se gastaron unos 2.400
millones ahora quieren gastarse casi el doble.
¿Funcionará esta vez? ¿Puede ser este plan
un esbozo de lo que necesita América Latina
a gran escala para escapar de la pobreza?
Atentos.
(EL PINCHAZO DE LA AYUDA NORTEAMERICANA)
Sí, la lluvia de billetes del tío Sam cayó
sobre América Central, pero las cosas no
han mejorado mucho. Ni siquiera está del
todo claro que todo ese dinero haya tenido
algún impacto relevante.
Por ejemplo, con el dinero norteamericano
se desarrollaron aplicaciones para que los
campesinos siguieran la cotización de los
productos agrícolas o la forma de gastar
el dinero de los gobiernos locales. En este
último programa se gastaron 30 millones de
dólares. El problema es que muchos campesinos,
por no decir la mayoría, no tenían smartphones
ni datos.
(También se mejoraron las instalaciones de
algunas escuelas, pero sin que ello mejorase
en nada la calidad docente. Decenas de miles
de campesinos recibieron charlas sobre cómo
mejorar sus cultivos pero cuando quisieron
buscar financiación para llevar a cabo los
nuevos proyectos les dijeron que el dinero
de Estados Unidos no estaba pensado para eso.
Se pusieron en marcha portales de transparencia
y webs, que luego nadie actualizaba.
Se gastaron 20 millones de dólares en instalar
baños en el campo, baños que al poco tiempo
los lugareños desmontaron para venderlos
como chatarra.)
Amigos, el 80% de los proyectos fueron encargados
a contratistas estadounidenses, que ni conocían
del todo el terreno ni tenían ningún incentivo
para ahorrar en “burocracia”. De hecho,
según muchos críticos en torno al 50% del
presupuesto se gasta en administración, salarios,
dietas y desplazamientos de las propias empresas
contratistas.
(“Es un negocio. Los mismos ejecutores ganan
los contratos una y otra vez, a pesar de haber
sido malos ejecutores en el pasado, sin mostrar
ningún nivel de impacto y sin cambiar nada”.
Carlos Ponce, Profesor de Gestión Empresarial
en la Universidad de Columbia)
Ahora bien, un momento, no penséis que todas
estas cosas fueron algo particular de la Alianza
por la Prosperidad. Para nada.
Lo cierto es que la inmensa mayor parte de
la Ayuda al desarrollo de Estados Unidos - y
de casi cualquier otro país - tiene problemas
similares.
Por ejemplo, la USAID, la Agencia de los Estados
Unidos para el Desarrollo Internacional es
la agencia del gobierno responsable de distribuir
la mayor parte de la ayuda gubernamental de
los Estados Unidos de corte no militar. Hablamos
de una agencia que tiene un presupuesto anual
de casi 60 mil millones de dólares.
Pues bien, se sabe que muchos proyectos, siendo
generosos con la propia agencia, digamos la
mitad del total, apenas logran la mitad de
los resultados previstos. Y eso, siendo también
muy generosos.
Porque lo cierto es que uno de los problemas
que tienen estas iniciativas es que es muy
complicado medir los resultados. Y si no lo
puedes medir, pues al final recurren a cosas
como el número de asistentes a una charla,
con independencia de si luego esta vale para
algo o no.
Por ejemplo, dos de los países dónde más
dinero ha depositado la ayuda norteamericana,
y en general la comunidad internacional, además
de América Central, han sido Afganistán
y Haití. [Mejor no comentamos nada, pero
desarrollo lo que es desarrollo, pues, no
mucho]
Este es el reto al que se enfrenta Kamala
Harris, armar un plan que no suponga dilapidar
4.000 millones en América Central.
(Para colmo, algunas investigaciones apuntan
a que la ayuda extranjera en América Central
es casi inutil a la hora de impulsar el desarrollo
y que incluso, al contrario de lo esperado,
pueden aumentar los niveles de emigración.
Digamos que los fondos repartidos financian
muchos viajes a Estados Unidos.)
En cualquier caso, regresando a la pregunta
del principio sobre qué pueden hacer los
países ricos para apoyar la lucha contra
la pobreza en América Latina, quizás tengan
otras vías. Y el coronavirus ha sido un buen
ejemplo.
Amigos, los países pobres no necesitan peces,
ni tampoco, frente a lo que se ha dicho siempre,
cañas de pescar. Lo que necesitan es financiación
para poder comprarlas y montar luego negocios
dónde comercializar los peces.Y ganas, ganas
no les faltan.
Mejor que
gastarse decenas de millones en apps que no
van a ninguna parte sería mejor por ejemplo
armar programas de financiación participativa
en zonas muy pobres o abrir líneas para apoyar
microcréditos. También financiar el desarrollo
de asociaciones y cooperativas.
Aquí los datos que nos han pasado nuestros
amigos de Microwd son reveladores. A pesar
del coronavirus la rentabilidad de los proyectos
que están pilotando se ha incrementado. No
se ha reducido, sino que se ha incrementado.
Es decir, que las ganas por montar negocios
y salir adelante no han desaparecido, solo
hacen falta recursos para poder llevarlo a
cabo.
En fin, queríamos insistir una vez más con
este enfoque porque, ¿qué queréis que os
diga? Me parece muy revelador. ¡Qué mal
se hacen algunas cosas cuándo se dispara
con el dinero de todos! ¡Qué mal para todos!
Es muy fácil hablar de ayuda al desarrollo
pero muy difícil poner resultados sobre la
mesa.
Pero llegados hasta aquí, turno para ti:
¿Crees que el nuevo plan de Joe Biden y Kamala
Harris funcionará? ¿Aprenderán de los errores
pasados o seguiran dilapidando cientos y cientos
de millones de dólares en países que cada
vez están peor?
Déjanos tus impresiones por aquí abajo en
los comentarios y ya sabéis, si este vídeo
os ha resultado interesante no olvidéis darle
al botón de like.
Un saludo y hasta la próxima.